you know what i thought was over
happened recently was on clubhouse
bad luck squashed his [ __ ] with mustard
on clubhouse
and i remember being at south by
southwest
in 2000 and it was either 13 or 14.
and i don't know what happened but i
know some [ __ ] happened um
but it felt like yg had a lot of tension
with uh
it was a problem um
do you remember being around that era
yeah
you know like [ __ ] was you know it was
basically it was about the thing
complete things i'm saying and
[ __ ] have words you say i'm saying it
it took it it went farther than what the
post has been but
you know people be slick talking you
know what i mean but it gets over that
[ __ ] now but i feel like
that that was like a perfect example of
how la
street politics led into the music [ __ ]
and it's like
yo if we really think about back then
how fire would have been to see problem
and yg work together but do a whole
[ __ ] album
together like problem had it
like both of them had some like they had
it
you know what i'm saying that era was so
legendary in la history like
problem had welcome to mollywood yga
just read up like
it was a whole movement and both of them
from the same city
and it was some l.a politics [ __ ]
sometimes gets in the way of some
historical [ __ ]
do you feel like with la the politics
sometimes
because you know i just had this
conversation with um
with big u and whack we're talking about
how
sometimes the la politics have gotten in
the way of some real historical [ __ ]
happening in hip-hop
all that type of [ __ ] yeah because it
might not be
rapper a and rapper b having a real
problem with each other it's not about
that it's about
the politics of flow to run around them
and above them you know what i'm saying
is that some people
other like me being artists i hang with
a sun crew
this artist hanging with a certain crew
i'm saying somebody it's like they'd be
having inner beasts so it's looking like
it's a artist thing but it'd be really
the friends and
yeah yeah it ain't even about like you
ain't might even have a [ __ ] problem
with the guy
yeah but it's like hey i might be from
here and you might be from here but so
because of that like
this and this don't mesh
yeah oh you got a record with bad luck
yeah before that yeah i mean that's what
i'm saying we got we cool
it's just [ __ ] be falling out behind
other [ __ ] so
yeah well i thought it was dope i just
thought it was real dope to see bad luck
and uh and mustard get on
clubhouse and talk that [ __ ] out yeah
because it's like
yeah we're talking about some serious
errors of l.a hip-hop like
you know problem might not had had
and i no problem could have signed with
anyone at that when one problem was
was [ __ ] lit out here everyone
offered him a deal
but like to think he had that whole like
side of la hip hop and then yg
i mean yg we're talking about now he's
one of the i look at yg like our
our modern day snoop yeah you know what
i'm saying if kendrick is
dre yg is stoop
you know what i'm saying so i just think
that uh
yeah i always thought that was like a
and and what's cool about that though
too is i
don't feel like it ever really kind of
bled through the music too much
kind of stayed behind it was minor [ __ ]
that was said and spoke on here and
there and
certain little disc songs and you know i
mean minor [ __ ] but yeah for the most
part it didn't get too
out of hand